die begründung des angriffs vielen dank
wir haben mittlerweile
wechselten verfügen und die stäbe aber
vielleicht weiter denn wir sind das
einzige plan 07 das ist das
bundesministerium für justiz und
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann hat
dass wir diese ewigen stadt und weise
die putin den krieg in der ukraine
führen lässt ist in vielerlei hinsicht
verbrecherisch auf vielen ebenen werden
derzeit beweise für völker
strafrechtliche verbrechen russlands
gesichert der chefankläger beim
internationalen strafgerichtshof
ermittelt
euro just koordiniert die ermittlung
innerhalb der europäischen union auch
der
generalbundesanwalt ermittelt bereits im
rahmen eines struktur
ermittlungsverfahren damit ist klar wenn
die waffen sprechen schweigt das recht
nicht meine sehr geehrten kolleginnen
und kollegen
wir deutschen haben hier
eine besondere historische verantwortung
für die bekämpfung von kriegsverbrechen
daher haben wir im rahmen einer
pioniertat des
völkerstrafrechts bereits folterknechte
asads in deutschland nach dem
weltrechtsprinzip vor gericht gestellt
und wir werden auch russische
kriegsverbrecher in deutschland vor
gericht stellen wenn wir ihrer habhaft
werden niemand sollte unsere
entschlossenheit
unterschätzen nirgendwo
nirgendwo dürfen sich kriegsverbrecher
sicher fühlt erst recht nicht in
deutschland denn gerade bei uns gilt
wenn die waffen sprechen
schweigt das recht nicht
putin führt seinen krieg gegen die
ukraine
er führt ihn aber auch gegen die
prinzipien der liberalen demokratie
daher müssen wir der ukraine bei stehen
wir müssen aber auch die prinzipien der
liberalen demokratie verteidigen auch
bei uns hier zuhause und daher möchte
ich an dieser stelle klar sagen
den krieg gegen die ukraine führt der
russische präsident verbrecherisch aber
es ist kein verbrechen russisch zu sein
wer menschen ausgrenzen oder
diskriminieren möchte nur weil sie aus
russland stammen oder wald die russisch
sprechen verletzt die prinzipien der
liberalen demokratie das werden wir
nicht tolerieren meine damen und herren
deutschland bleibt
ein raum der freiheit der sicherheit und
des rechts
egal woher ein mensch kommt und welche
sprache er spricht denn unrecht bekämpft
man nicht mit unrecht meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen
die werte der liberalen demokratie sind
die entscheidung der mehrheit
und die freiheit des individuums
der publizist verrät zakaria warnte
schon
2003 also lange bevor der terminus
geläufig wurde vor liberalen demokratie
damit meint er ein staatswesen
dass der mehrheit alles erlaubt und dem
individuum nichts an respekt
entgegenbringt denn eines ist ja wahr
wenn alle über alles abstimmen bestimmt
am ende niemand mehr über sich selbst
und deshalb legt die ampel koalition
gerade so viel wert auf beide werte die
demokratie und die freiheit daher
stärken wir den respekt vor dem
individuum denn genau das ist ja gerade
das liberale an der liberalen demokratie
genau deshalb stärken wir die
bürgerrechte durch die ersetzung der
vorratsdatenspeicherung und reform bei
der quellen theke genau deshalb stärken
wir die selbstbestimmung im
familienrecht durch neue möglichkeiten
in einer neuen zeit und genau deshalb
werden wir eine grundrechts orientierte
und evidenzbasierte sicherheitspolitik
betreiben wir erstellen eine
überwachungs gesamtrechnung mit blick
auf die bestehenden sicherheitsgesetze
und wir unterziehen die
überwachungsbefugnisse des staates einer
generalrevision all das war schon
richtig
das war schon richtig als wir den
koalitionsvertrag
abgeschlossen haben aber in anbetracht
des verbrecherischen angriffs auf die
prinzipien der liberalen demokratie ist
all das noch wichtiger geworden als es
eh schon war liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
aus dem bundesministerium der justiz
leisten wir unsere beiträge dazu wir tun
die so dass dies hoffentlich auch aus
sicht strenger haushälter bestehen kann
denn im vergleich geben wer nicht
besonders viel geld aus nehmen dafür
aber besonders viel von diesem geld
selber wieder ein
und deshalb meine ich
jeder euro für das haus des rechts und
der freiheit ist eine gute investition
in die liberale demokratie herrschen
soweit
bundesjustizminister marco buschmann hat
hier die freiheit besonders betonen das
hat er auch schon häufiger gesagt dass
er sich als verteidiger der freiheit in
seiner rolle als justizminister versteht
dass im moment die wahlen zum
parlamentarischen
kontrollgremium laufen da vor ende der
debatte zum justiz haushalt die beiden
abgeschlossen werden wird natürlich der
minister genauso wie abgeordnete die
jetzt zu diesem geschäftsbereich ja an
der debatte teilnehmen zwischendurch mal
kurze zeit den saal verlassen um von
ihrem wahlrecht entsprechend
gebrauch zu machen
wir beginnen mit der debatte und der
kollege dr günter krings hat für die cdu
csu fraktion das wort
frau präsidentin dass ich zu beginn
meiner rede auf das alternativprogramm
aufmerksam machen nehme ich ihn nicht
weiter übel ich kann die situation
verstehen auch bundesminister meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren der
freiheitliche verfassungsstaat hat exakt
zwei mittel um politisch zu agieren um
lebenswirklichkeit zu gestalten geld
also die einnahme von steuern und die
ausgabe dieser gelder andererseits und
zum zweiten gesetzgebung und
rechtsdurchsetzung
regelmäßig habe ich den eindruck dass
wir im umgang mit dem handlungs mittel
geld auch hier im hause viel
skrupelloser sind als im umgang mit dem
recht aber für uns recht würde ich ja da
habe ich das gegenteil jedenfalls
behaupten meine damen und herren aber
weder freiheit noch rechtsstaatlichkeit
sind eben in euro und cent aufzugeben
und das werden wir in diesen wochen sehr
eindrücklich bei dem tapferen kampf des
ukrainischen volkes gegen die russischen
invasion aber auch bei unserem
sanktionen als antwort auf diesen
angriffskrieg
dieser krieg wird europa verändern er
wird deutschland verändern vieles von
dem was wir bislang
gesagt und gehofft haben hat seine
gültigkeit verloren
der russische präsident führt hier nicht
nur einen krieg gegen die ukraine
sondern auch gegen die demokratie und
dafür zugleich krieg gegen recht und
rechtsstaatlichkeit nicht nur dass wir
hier zeuge des größten völkerrechts
bruchs in der europäischen
nachkriegsgeschichte sein müssen
sondern mit der geplanten besetzung der
ukraine geht es dem kriegsverbrecher in
kemel auch darum keine rechtsstaatlichen
strukturen in seiner nachbarschaft
aufkommen zu lassen
die ukraine setzen ihr leben
für die freiheit und die unter vielen
widrigkeiten ja auch bekannte
rechtsstaatlichkeit in ihrem land und
sie haben auch deshalb unser aller
unterstützung von dietmar dath
auf diesem aus diesem grunde habe ich
mich in dieser woche einer petition
angeschlossen die die schaffung eines
weiteren neuen internationalen
sondertribunals für die russischen
kriegsverbrecher fordert nicht als
konkurrenz zu anderen möglichkeiten der
aufarbeitung als ergänzung dazu und den
partnerschaft dazu
und herr bundesminister ich konnte ihn
sehr viele insbesondere zum thema
ukraine zustimmen was sie gesagt haben
aber ich muss auch sagen während die
ampel regierung den etat des
generalbundesanwalts in diesen zeiten
doch tatsächlich senken will regel ich
dringend an richtig dringend an auch
namens seiner fraktion dass wir im
haushalt des generalbundesanwalts
zusätzliche stellen und mittel
bereitstellen um russische
kriegsverbrechen für künftige verfahren
zu dokumentieren wir sollten dabei auch
ukrainische flüchtlinge ermutigen uns
entsprechende hinweise informationen zu
geben damit wir diesen verbrechen
nachgehen können meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren die
furchtbaren berichtete uns täglich aus
diesem krieg erreichen relativieren
natürlich manche in politisch
kontroverse und doch kann die
weltpolitische lage natürlich auch
niemals eine entschuldigung sein für
fehler oder schludrigkeiten auf einer
nationalen politik und auch darüber
müssen wir reden
wer allen ernstes etwa die abschaffung
sie kennen das thema des werbeverbots
für schwangerschafts abbrüche zur ersten
rechtspolitischen priorität erklärt wie
es in der ampel geschehen ist der sollte
so meine wirklich herzliche bitte sein
politisches koordinatensystem doch noch
einmal einer kritischen überprüfung
unterziehen ich erwarte bei einem
solchen thema zumindest vieles gleich
zumindest dass die grenzen die unser
grundgesetz und das verfassungsgericht
zum schutz ungeborener kinder gezogen
hat auch ernst genommen werden und ich
erwarte ehrlichkeit ehrlichkeit in der
debatte vielleicht schon zu viel
verlangt ich weiß es nicht denn
derjenige
derjenige der ein werbeverbot streichen
nimmt dadurch schon denkt logisch
werbung zumindest zumindest billigend in
kauf billigend in kauf wer das
grundrecht auf leben und die
menschenwürde des embryos eben gering
schätzt handelt wie ich finde auch nicht
liberal da geht um grundwerte und
freiheitsrechte und das gegenteil von
liberal sind eben auch die pläne für ein
neues kinder grund tritt nur ein
weiteres beispiel zu nennen wir als
union wollen kinder mit und nicht gegen
ihre eltern schützen das war der kern
der von uns mit ausgearbeiteten
vorschlag in der letzten wahlperiode die
ampel wir hingegen mehr staatlichen
einfluss bei der kindererziehung zu
lasten der eltern die damit angestrebte
staatliche lufthoheit über den
kinderbetten die kennen wir von olaf
scholz aber bislang nicht von liberale
ja meine damen und herren ich habe
inzwischen den eindruck dass die fdp
hier nicht nur ihre sitzplätze für uns
als unions fraktion frei gemacht hat
sondern gleich noch ihre liberalen
positionen ein gutes stück torte
freigeräumt hat schon
ich will aber auch
gerne noch auf einen kleinen erfolg des
justizministers und seines ministeriums
eingehen nämlich die gewinnung der
zuständigkeit für den normenkontrollrat
und damit für das wichtige thema der
besseren rechtsetzung
2006 hat eine cdu geführte
bundesregierung die thematik ganz
bewusst im bundeskanzleramt angesiedelt
das hat die bedeutung der aufgabe
unterstrichen aber auch die
durchschlagskraft des normenkontrollrats
ganz erheblich erhöht oder erst wirklich
geschaffen
dass die ampel mehrheit nun eine
zuständigkeit verschiebung in ein
fachressort vornimmt zeigt dass die
koalition insgesamt das thema nicht mehr
so ganz ernst
das ist schlecht für die sache
aber aber baue gerne brücke wenn das
justizministerium diese aufgabe denn
jetzt schon an land gezogen hat das
freut mich ja für den minister dann
machen sie bitte auch was draus ja und
die sorge habe ich ihnen das nicht
gerade erklären warum ich die sorge habe
herr kollege der wahlslogan der fdp im
bundestagswahlkampf war glaube ich nie
gab es mehr zu tun und er passt hier
wirklich leider wie die faust aufs auge
bei dem thema ja
defizite bei der gesetzgebungs qualität
gab es auch in den letzten jahren
unstreitig aber was wir bei den ersten
arbeitstagen der ampelkoalition erleben
durften erleben mussten ist wirklich ein
neuer tiefpunkt in sachen qualität der
gesetzgebung
und ich denke ich vielleicht mal ein
beispiel noch ganz frisch aus der
letzten sitzungswoche novellierung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
indem sie ihren auf dem bisherigen
höhepunkt der ansteckungszahlen das gros
der schutzmaßnahmen abgeschafft haben
haben sie den charakter des
infektionsschutz rechts schlichtweg
verkannt es ist eben kein klassisches
gefahrenabwehr recht sondern vor allem
risikovorsorge recht ein solches gesetz
darf also niemals nur die aktuelle
gefahrenlage abdecken sondern es muss
auch noch funktionieren wenn diese sich
verschärft wenn es aber die länder macht
und wehrlos macht ist es eben kein
vorausschauendes sondern ein schlechtes
gesetz wenn man so damit begründet wir
können es ja nur nachbessern ist das
eigentlich denkbar schwächste begründung
und rechtfertigung für ein gesetz meinen
damit seien
aber auch der weg zu diesem gesetz
schreibt geschichte in der
geschäftsordnung der bundesregierung ist
dass guten grund vorgeschrieben dass vor
einem kabinettsbeschluss die fachlich
kompetenten verbände zu beteiligen sind
die beteiligung gab es auch die begann
mittwochnacht um 18 und endete 8 stunden
52 minuten später sie haben es wirklich
geschafft verbände beteiligen bei einem
zentralen gesetz zu einer bloßen farce
verkommen zu lassen und wohlgemerkt
dieser zeitdruck ist nicht durch die
dynamik der pandemie entstanden dann
wirst du noch verstehen sondern weil
sich die ressorts an der stelle
ineinander verkeilt haben
und das haben übrigens auch gemacht bei
der frage impfpflicht das grundgesetz
weist dem bundestag die entscheidung bei
solche wichtigen fragen zu die regierung
liegt ein regierungsentwurf zug und
teilt nicht großzügig gewissensfragen
dem parlament zu das ist nämlich keine
starken sondern eine schwächung des
parlaments was ich ihr unternommen haben
meine damen und herren in zentralen
regelungs bedürftigen fragen vor die
teil gar keinen gesetzentwurf vorzulegen
wie hier ist aber noch kein beitrag für
bessere rechtsetzung vielen dank
günter krings war das der
rechtspolitische sprecher der
unionsfraktion und meine damen und
herren sie sehen es schon an diesen
tagen da ist natürlich an vielen orten
der welt etwas worüber wir berichten
wollen demnächst erwarten wir die
pressekonferenz von generalsekretär der
nato jetzt stoltenberg nach dem
gipfeltreffen der nato in brüssel zum
russischen krieg gegen die ukraine
sollte es dort losgehen werden wir das
live senden so lange bleiben wir aber
natürlich hier in der debatte jetzt mit
esther die ich ja für die spd-fraktion
im bundeshaushalt sind im zweiten
regierungsentwurf einnahmen und ausgaben
in höhe von jeweils 4 157 milliarden
euro veranschlagt bei steuereinnahmen
höhe von 332 milliarden euro im justiz
haushalt also in diesem einzelplan 07
den wir jetzt beraten werden
gesamtausgaben von rund 935 millionen
euro und einnahmen von 644 millionen
euro oder nicht steuereinnahmen sondern
eigene einnahmen eingestellt also
beträgt der anteil der ausgaben des
justiz haushaltes am gesamthaushalt
lediglich 0,2 prozent und es ist ein
verwaltungshaushalt das gibt nicht viel
spielraum für projekte förderprogramme
oder zusätzliche neue ausgaben seien
umschichten in einem
vorgang hier fast schier unmöglich ist
das justizministerium ist in erster
linie dass gesetzgebung ministerium
entweder durch eigene gesetze oder durch
begleitung der anderen ministerien in
deren gesetzgebungsprozesse dafür sind
ausgaben von 127 millionen eingestellt
in den letzten zwei jahren kamen aus dem
bundesministerium der justiz
beschleunigt durch die herausforderungen
der bewohner pandemie wichtige gesetze
im sanierungs und insolvenzrecht die
verkürzung der restschuldbefreiung die
mietpreis bremsen schutz vor
wohnungskündigung bei mietschulden und
so weiter ich möchte das jetzt hier in
die ich alles weiter ausführen im
haushalt des bundesministeriums der
justiz entfällt in dieser legislatur das
kapitel der verbraucherpolitik was ich
persönlich sehr bedauerlich das betrifft
betreut hat auch im rechtsausschuss und
wir das mal sehr viel spaß gemacht hat
zum zuständigkeit des bundesministeriums
der justiz gehören drei von fünf
bundesgerichten nämlich der
bundesgerichtshof das
bundesverwaltungsgericht und der
bundesfinanzhof sowie der
generalbundesanwalt und dafür sind
ausgaben vorgesehen von insgesamt 162
millionen euro
auch der zentrale dienstleister der
deutschen justiz nämlich das bundesamt
für justiz wird mit haushaltsmitteln im
einzelplan und sieben veranschlagt und
zwar mit ausgaben in höhe von 990
millionen hier möchte ich aber einmal
die einnahmenseite näher beleuchten
jeder der bereits einmal ein
führungszeugnis beantragt hat hat dazu
beigetragen dass dem justiz haushalt
dadurch auch einnahmen zufließen
1200 beschäftigte bieten im bundesamt
unter anderem bürgerdienst zb neben dem
führungszeugnis auch hilfe bei
auslandsadoptionen auslands unterhalt
internationalen sorgerecht sie führen
die register bei der muster
feststellungsklage das
gewerbezentralregister und sind
schlichtungsstelle für den luftschlag
wenn man auf der seite nachdruck der
wird überrascht sein was das bundesamt
für justiz alles leistet
sie bieten dienstleistungen für gerichte
und behörden zum beispiel justiz
fortbildung internationale rechtshilfe
in strafsachen sowie im zivil- und
handelssachen
und sie sind zuständig fühlt die
vollstreckung von geldstrafen und
geldbußen sowie auch bei eu
kontopfändung und insgesamt sind dafür
im haushalt einnahmen in höhe von 135
millionen die also über den ausgaben
liegen veranschlagt ein weitaus größerer
betrag wird an einnahmen für gewerbliche
schutzrechte im rahmen von gebühren in
höhe von 455 millionen beim deutschen
patent und markenamt geschätzt bei
ausgaben von
245 millionen euro auch da liegen die
einnahmen über den ausgaben und liebe
kolleginnen kollegen das ist ein
ausdruck dafür dass deutschland ein
forschungs und innovationsstandort ist
und das findet sich im justiz haushalt
wieder dieser indikator ich finde das
großartig
selbst in der krise oder vielleicht
gerade die krise hat die anmeldung von
patenten im bereich von
umweltfreundlichen antriebstechniken im
bereich von digitalisierung
medizintechnik infektionsschutz und
anderen bereichen beflügelt darauf
können wir alle stolz einige kolleginnen
und kollegen sie sehen es ist eine
besonderheit dieses zwar kleinen aber
trotzdem sehr bedeutsamen haushalts des
bundesministeriums der justiz
es besteht nämlich eine mehr als 68
prozentige deckungsquote
die bundesrepublik ist ein moderner
verfassungsstaat der drei wesentliche
aufgaben hat zum ersten die äußere
sicherheit also die landesverteidigung
zum zweiten die innere sicherheit also
der frieden in der gesellschaft und zum
dritten die gesellschaftsgestaltung
darunter verstehen wir all das was wir
mit sozialer sicherung und
daseinsvorsorge in verbindung bringen
ich meine grundvoraussetzung ist dabei
zunächst die innere sicherheit die
bürgerinnen und bürger erwarten von uns
nicht dass alles perfekt funktioniert
dass jede ungerechtigkeit aufgelöst
jedes verbrechen verhindert und jeder
oder jede grenzenlose freiheit genießen
kann zumindest die mehrheit erwartet
dass nicht in diesem haus und diese
grundsätze sind verfassungsmäßig
verankerte
artikel 20 grundgesetz begründet für die
bundesrepublik unter anderem das
sozialstaatsprinzip das
demokratieprinzip und das
rechtsstaatsprinzip sie werden sich
fragen warum ist mir diese klarstellung
in dieser haushaltsdebatte so wichtig
mir ist das wichtig weil das
bundesministerium der justiz ein
gesetzgebungs ministerium ist das an die
verfassungsmäßige ordnung gebunden ist
weil bei uns die vollziehende gewalt und
die rechtsprechung an gesetz und recht
gebunden sind und ich finde unser
rechtsstaat funktioniert liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich finde es beschämend dass ein
demokratisch gewählter abgeordneter hier
von der rechten seite in
russland in medien behaupten darf es
gebe in deutschland keine demokratie und
andere meinungen würden durch regierende
elite in deutschen medien im internet
und sogar durch körperliche gewalt
unterdrückt und es bestürzt mich
zutiefst dass durch solche äußerungen
dem kriegstreiber putin von deutschen
abgeordneten schützenhilfe geleistet
wird
es ist fast unerträglich war es macht
mich nicht stumpf denn die freiheit von
abgeordneten die hass und hetze gegen
deutschland verbreiten endet genau
hier wo meine freiheit beginnt freiheit
ist nämlich hier auf erden nicht
grenzenlos hier ist die grenze und ich
bin dankbar dass wir in deutschland
freiheitsrechte haben die durch unsere
verfassung garantiert werden
handlungsfreiheit in artikel 2
meinungsfreiheit in artikel 5
versammlungsfreiheit in artikel 8 die
die rechte anderer nicht verletzen
dürfen und nur beschränkt werden können
durch ein gesetz sie verbrannten sie
bestätigen das ja gerade dass sie das
sogar auch noch gut finden was war
passiert
in russland zu behaupten in deutschland
gebe es keine demokratie und keine
meinungsfreiheit ist ein vernichtender
schlag ins gesicht aller menschen in
russland die gegen diesen krieg auf die
straße gehen die sich öffentlichen
rundfunk und fernsehen gegen diesen
krieg und frieden aussprechen die mutig
widerstand leisten und damit um ihr
leben fürchten müssen ich bin entsetzt
wie weit sie hier im rechten rand gehen
um sich verbündete zu suchen und die
äußerungen ihres kollegen kommentiert
bis auf einen kurzen kommentar des
stellvertretenden bundessprecher der ja
hier auch schon wieder von der rechten
seite das zwischenruf stehen lassen
mir fällt es schwer ihre redebeiträge zu
ertragen und trotzdem nehmen die
demokratischen parteien in diesem haus
diese herausforderung an aber
meinungsfreiheit bedeutet nicht dass wir
ihre hetzerischen kommentare
widerspruchslos hinnehmen müssen nein
genau hier ist der ort um sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen
aber nicht von ihnen herr brandner in
der öffentlichen debatte denn unsere
demokratie hält das aus und ich bin
überzeugt die mehrheit der
demokratischen parteien hier im haus die
sich zu unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung bekennt und
diese nicht verleugnet sieht das genauso
wie ich verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen
unser rechtsstaat funktioniert und das
verdanken wir unseren gesetzgebungs
ministerium dessen haushalt wir hier
debattieren sowie vielen engagierten
beschäftigten in justiz und den
gerichten die in der panama an ihre
grenzen gekommen sind ich freue mich auf
spannende haushaltsberatungen ich habe
mich vom ministerium schon so einiges
gehört was man vielleicht auch noch mal
anpacken könnte dafür werden zusätzliche
ausgaben erforderlich mal gucken ob wir
da noch was verändern können vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
beste deutsche war das für die
sozialdemokraten ist hier in ihre rede
sehr lange auf eine äußerung eingegangen
auf ein interview der kfd
bundestagsabgeordneter sein verfügung
gilt das heißt die maske kann hier form
von der amtierenden präsidentin
abgenommen werden wenn sie die
rednerinnen und redner aufruft oder
hinweise zur debatte gibt und natürlich
von der aktuellen rednerinnen oder dem
aktuellen redner am pult für
zwischenrufe haben wir schon seit wochen
die praxis dass die maske mund und nase
weiter bedeckt das wort als ich hier
noch eine äußerung von
bundestagsvizepräsidentin petra pau und
nun kann die afg auf die vorherige rede
antworten michael espendiller spricht
jetzt für seine fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
und bei youtube freiheit demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit diesen dreiklang
haben wir diese woche hier in diesem
raum schon häufig gehört
gebetsmühlenartig wiederholt doch wie
genau steht es eigentlich damit die
freiheit des menschen liegt nicht darin
dass er tun kann was er will sondern
dass er nicht tun muss was er nicht will
das sagte rose
nun bedeutet das dass man keine steuern
mehr zahlen muss oder kirchen nicht mehr
bezahlen muss je natürlich nicht wobei
da beginnt sich die geister durchaus
schon zu scheiden bei der höhe der
steuern oder die höhe der bußgelder
beides übrigens kritisiert von der fdp
während ihrer oppositionszeit weist das
hier noch jemand diese flammende
plädoyers gegen die finanzielle
ausbeutung der bürger und den kampf für
die freiheit der kampf gegen
übergriffige corona maßnahmen für mehr
wissenschaftlichkeit bei der politischen
entscheidungsfindung gegen einen
bevormundenden staat und für mehr
eigenverantwortung und natürlich der
kampf gegen die impfpflicht unsere
gesellschaft hat noch nie so tiefe
einschnitte in ihr gewohntes leben
hinnehmen müssen wie den letzten zwei
jahren der korona politik und während
ganz zu beginn noch alle auf die
maßnahmen vertraut haben wurde den
meisten menschen relativ schnell klar
dass man sich nicht ewig vor einem virus
verstecken kann die politik der
koalition von union und spd griff das
auf und versprach den menschen die
rückkehr zur normalität sobald es in
eine impfung gebe eine impfung die für
alle verfügbar sein sollte aber wo
natürlich niemand gezwungen werden
sollte sie zu nehmen bis hierhin war
noch alles halbwegs normal aber ab einem
gewissen punkt wurde die pandemie nicht
mehr überwiegend rational bekämpft
sondern sie wurde zu einem spielball der
üblichen politische spielchen die die
konsens parteien hier untereinander
spielen und die übrigens mit der sache
nichts mehr zu tun haben und auch nicht
mehr mit dem wohle des volkes es stand
verschiedene wahl an und jede partei
hatte gegen die jeweils andere partei
ein und diese der politische granate in
der hand und da stand sinngemäß drauf
die maßnahmen sind nicht ausreichend
wegen ihrer partei sterben menschen und
was folgte war ein überbietungswettlauf
anforderungen da besseren härteren
endgültige rinnen und mehr und mehr und
mehr maßnahmen via cfd haben diesen
irrsinn sehr früh erkannt kritisiert und
uns für eine schrittweise rücknahme der
maßnahmen eingesetzt
die eben erwähnte granate schlug dann
natürlich auch in unsere richtung aber
zum glück lautet unser partei motto mut
zur wahrheit aber auch der fdp erkannte
irgendwann dass ein relevanter
wähleranteil da ist der sich ein ende
dieser ganzen maßnahmen wünschte und
mehr noch man durfte die unzufriedenen
ja nicht zur ard wechseln lassen also
begann auch die fdp den maßnahmen
irrsinn zu kritisieren und sie bekamen
auch dankbaren zuspruch das wurde später
sogar noch verstärkt und zwar als die
bürger nach sehr viel geduld sich
endlich an die deutsche gerichtsbarkeit
erinnert haben und klagten doch die
gerichte auf die unsere bürger in ihrem
glauben an rechtsstaatlichkeit alles
gesetzt hatten fanden das alles so in
ordnung mit den maßnahmen ich kann mich
noch gut daran erinnern als ich damals
noch mit juristen gesprochen habe die
schockiert die waren und die bürger die
schon so viel haben auf sich nehmen
müssen fühlten sich auf einen schlag
machtlos und im stich gelassen aber es
gab hoffnung auf erlösung denn die
herren kubicki lindner buschmann
kämpften für die freiheit und
versprachen keine impfpflicht
einzuführen ich muss gestehen ich habe
ihnen damals auch durchaus geglaubt und
ich habe mich auch sehr darüber gefreut
dass nicht nur die afg zu einem realen
politik kurs zurückgekommen ist und
genau deshalb kann ich sehr gut
nachvollziehen wie verraten verkauft und
verarscht sich ihre wähler jetzt führen
sie unterstützen jetzt alles wogegen sie
gekämpft haben und ein
fdp-justizminister der nicht klar und
deutlich sagt dass die geplante
impfpflicht ein absolutes no go ist
nicht die rechtsstaatliche rote fahne
hebt und einen lauterbach nicht
entschieden widerspricht der ist ein
schlag ins gesicht für alle freunde der
freiheit
die frage die frage nach der
kompromisslosen verteidigung des rechts
auf körperliche selbstbestimmung wäre
für mich für meine fraktion ein
absolutes deal oder no deal aber die fdp
5 einer koalition zur mehrheit die genau
das abschaffen möchte und niemand der
ein herz in der brust und ein minimum an
erinnerungsvermögen hat wird ihnen das
jemals verzeihen vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
michael espendiller war das setzt im
haushaltsausschuss wie auch der nächste
redner das ist bruno höhnel für bündnis
90 die grünen hier in der debatte zum
einzelplan 07 des
bundesjustizministeriums die grünen hat
nun der kollege bruno
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lieber herr
buschmann aston villa von einer partei
die vom verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem verdachtsfall eingeordnet
ist lassen wir uns nix über die
verfassungsmäßigkeit unserer
gesetzgebung seien nur da wir das mal
wissen kehren sie ihre eigenen haustür
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir beraten den einzelplan 7 den etat
des justizministeriums und im zentrum
dieser debatte stehen damit unweigerlich
unser rechtsstaat und unsere demokratie
der funktionierende rechtsstaat ist eine
wesentliche säule unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung ja die
unabhängige gerichtsbarkeit ist das
fundament unserer freien und offenen
gesellschaft
der wert von freiheit und demokratie
ist unermesslich und er wird uns in
diesen tagen durch den
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
putins brutal vor augen geführt und man
kann es nicht oft genug sagen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
bundesregierung wir als parlamentarier
stehen gemeinsam und unverrückbar
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern an der seite der ukraine und
dafür bin ich in allen sehr dankbar
der etat des bmj ist mit 597 millionen
euro für personalausgaben im großen maß
von kontinuität und stabilität geprägt
so wie eben auch unser rechtsstaat und
wenn sie mir eine bemerkung erlauben
lieber herr buschmann dass sie als eines
ihrer ersten vorhaben in ihrer ja noch
recht kurzen amtszeit gemeinsam mit
ministerin eine spiegel die streichung
des 219 aus dem strafgesetzbuch
vorangetrieben haben das rechne ich ihm
hoch an herr buschmann endlich kommen
wir in der gesellschaftlichen realität
des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts an
endlich machen wir schluss mit diesen
unrecht 219 es höchste zeit liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
sie sehen wir haben uns als koalition
einiges vorgenommen der einzug der
digitalisierung in die justiz wird in
den kommenden jahren von dieser
regierung vorangebracht wir legen dafür
den digital pakt für die justiz auf und
klar bei dabei ist und das will ich
unmissverständlich auch als mitglied der
partei bündnis 90 die grünen klar machen
wir werden dabei ein besonderes
augenmerk auf die konsequente wahrung
der bürger/innen rechte und des
datenschutz legen
sehr geehrte damen und herren lassen sie
mich diese gelegenheit nutzen und an
dieser stelle den gemeinnützigen
stiftungen und vereinen danken die ja
aus diesem etat gefördert werden und die
eine extrem wichtige arbeit leisten in
unserem gemeinsamen kampf gegen
diskriminierung gegen rassismus und
gegen antisemitismus
die entsprechenden ansätze im entwurf
werden auch hohem niveau verstetigt in
teilen erhöht beispielsweise bei der
stiftung forum recht um eine million
euro oder auch bei der internationalen
stiftung für rechtliche zusammenarbeit
und 460.000 euro wir stärken die arbeit
für vielfalt gerechtigkeit und
demokratie das ist das richtige signal
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und mit blick auf die justizbehörden ist
festzuhalten dass der pakt für den
rechtsstaat wirkung entfaltet hat auch
wenn wir in einigen feldern sicherlich
noch nachholbedarf haben herauskaufen
möchte ich hier exemplarisch die
hasskriminalität wo wir nach wie vor das
muss man sagen ein vollzugsdefizit haben
bund und ländern müssen gemeinsam noch
besser darin werden diese straftaten
frühzeitig zu erkennen diese anschläge
auf unser grundgesetz konsequent zu
verfolgen und zu ahnden da sind wir
gemeinsam in der verantwortung
egal ob in der analogen welt oder im
digitalen raum das internet ist eben
kein rechtsfreier paralleluniversum hat
es ist keine meinung und das werden wir
auch ihren rechten trollen ganz ganz
deutlich machen darauf können sie sich
verlassen
und was passiert wenn wir die bedeutung
des rechtsstaatlichkeit prinzips wie es
sich aus unserem grundgesetz artikel 20
ergibt wenn wir diese bedeutung nicht
unentwegt hochhalten ja wenn wir unsere
lebendige demokratie nicht mit allen
mitteln verteidigen was dann passiert
das können wir in der in russland sehen
wo kritische stimmen weggesperrt und
mundtot gemacht werden wo die justiz
längst nicht mehr unabhängig ist wo ein
klima der angst vor behörden herrscht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen im
inneren wie im äußeren wir stellen uns
derartigen tendenzen mit aller kraft
entgegen wir stehen für eine bürgernahe
für eine transparente justiz auf
augenhöhe wir schützen den rechtsstaat
und wir verteidigen unsere lebendige
demokratie wehrhaft ist gegen die feinde
der freiheit auch die die da ganz rechts
sitzen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit liebe kollegen politik
ohne hohe niveau das für bündnis 90 die
grünen im bundestag wir warten weiterhin
auf die pressekonferenz des
generalsekretärs der natur jens
stoltenberg nach dem gipfeltreffen der
nato und brüssel mittlerweile tragen
sich diese pressekonferenz verschoben
ist jetzt für 4 2 angekündigt wir halten
sie natürlich auf dem laufenden und hier
im plenum im bundestag spricht ein
klarer bünger rechtspolitische
sprecherin der linksfraktion
sehr geehrte präsidentin sehr geehrter
herr bundesminister liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die bundesregierung hat in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag
angekündigt dass sie das strafrecht auf
den prüfstand stellen will das begrüßen
wir ankündigung reichen aber nicht aus
sie müssen die vorhaben auch umsetzen
herr buschmann sie haben es selbst in
einem interview gesagt weniger menschen
sollen wegen sogenannter
ersatzfreiheitsstrafen in haft kommen
denn wer zu einer geldstrafe verurteilt
wird und diese nicht bezahlen kann muss
stattdessen ins gefängnis andere länder
der eu sind wir viel weiter und auch in
deutschland muss endlich etwas passieren
streichen sie die ersatzfreiheitsstrafe
zumindest bewege liegen die die gar kein
geld haben die ersatzfreiheitsstrafe ist
mittlerweile zur häufigsten form der
freiheitsstrafe geworden darauf weist
auch der jurist bohnen steinke
2009 10 saßen schätzungsweise 51 tausend
personen hinter gittern allein aus dem
grund weil sie eine strafe nicht zahlen
konnten damit werden arme menschen
doppelt bestraft von
ersatzfreiheitsstrafen sind besonders
häufig menschen getroffen die ohne
ticket im öffentlichen verkehr fahren
nach § 265 a des strafgesetzbuches wird
mit freiheitsstrafe bis zu einem jahr
oder mit geldstrafe bestraft wer sich
die beförderung durch ein verkehrsmittel
erschleicht zum vergleich wer
beispielsweise ohne parkschein parkt
muss ein bußgeld bezahlen begeht aber
keine straftat alles andere wäre auch
heute vollkommen unverhältnismäßig das
ist beim fahren ohne fahrschein aber
auch rückt deshalb wollen wir diese
ungleichbehandlung abschaffen
2020 gab es über
43.000 verurteilung wegen fahrens ohne
fahrschein meistens geht es dabei um
geldstrafen trotzdem müssen schätzungen
zufolge jedes jahr mehrere tausend
menschen in den knast weil sie ohne
ticket gefahren sind und wen betrifft
das nicht diejenigen die einfach
vergessen haben sich ein ticket zu
kaufen sondern arme und prekär lebende
menschen obdachlose und suchtkranke die
sich kein ticket leisten können und erst
recht keine geldstrafe bezahlen können
und ich will ihnen sagen der damalige
spd politiker karl liebknecht hat den
begriff klassenjustiz geprägt natürlich
hat sich seitdem viel gewandelt aber
eines hat sich nicht geändert vor dem
gesetz sind nicht alle gleich das ist
ungerecht und das muss sich aus unserer
sicht ändern
von eingehen ist oder vermeintlichen
schwarzfahrerin kommt es regelmäßig zu
gewaltexzessen schnell mal ein beispiel
im märz 20 21 wird ein mann von einem
polizeihund der bund der bundespolizei
gejagt und wird von beamten überwältigt
gefesselt und zur polizeiwache gebracht
was hat dieser mann getan er war nicht
gewalttätig gegenüber anderen menschen
nein er ist ohne ticket im
regionalexpress gefahren das ist kein
einzelfall immer wieder kommt es hier zu
übergriffen dieser umgang mit menschen
weil sie sich kein ticket leisten können
ist absolut unverhältnismäßig deshalb
werden wir zur streichung des § 265 a 1
ein gesetzentwurf einprägt und
trecker und 18 haben wir das gemeinsam
mit den grünen gefordert ich weiß dass
es für einige von ihnen wie der kollegin
canan bayram ein wichtiges thema ist ich
bitte sie dass sie uns an dieser stelle
unterstützen
denn die initiative freiheit hat hier im
übrigen schon großartiges geleistet die
aktivistin sind nämlich der meinung dass
man sich nicht auf die politik verlassen
kann das ist ja auch in gewisser weise
verständlich die initiative befreiten
nämlich deutschlandweit menschen aus dem
gefängnis wegen fahrens ohne fahrschein
die hinter gittern sind deshalb sie
haben bisher 305 personen freigekauft
424 1051 hafttage aufgelöst und dem
staat damit 3,6 millionen euro erspart
die die inhaftierung der menschen noch
gekostet hätte vielen dank an euch an
dieser stelle
ersatz
die sind nämlich nicht nur ungerecht
nein sie sind auch noch teuer für die
steuerzahlerin wenn wir den 265
anstreichen dann sorgen wir nicht nur
für eine enorme entlastung bei den
gerichten sondern auch in den
justizanstalten außerdem würde man einen
paragraphen den die nazis 1935 aus dass
sozialdarwinistischen gründen eingeführt
haben aus dem stgb entfernen dafür ist
wirklich höchste zeit
um die ungleichbehandlung im recht zu
verringern braucht es natürlich mehr als
dass das ist klar es braucht auch eine
gut ausgestattete justiz und der
personal-etat im haushaltsplan sollte
daher noch viel deutlicher aufgestockt
werden und es sollte in lebens
strafverfahren auch pflichtverteidigerin
für alle geben vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat dr thorsten liebt für die
fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundesminister buschmann
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen lieber
herr kollege doktor krings ich danke
ganz herzlich für die vorlesung die sie
uns vorhin haben angedeihen lassen aber
ich kann ihnen versichern sie brauchen
sich keine sorgen zu machen um den
liberalen kompass der fdp in dieser
bundesregierung während wir
während hier zur beseitigung von
rechtsunsicherheit zb den 219 a stgb
abschaffen ist es doch ihre fraktion
sind es ihre parteien die bei jedem
publikumsträchtigen öffentlichen
ereignis nach neuen strafvorschriften
oder nach verstößen von
strafvorschriften sorgen und das ist
keine liberale
justizpolitik liberale justizpolitik ist
das was wir machen
es ist mir ganz persönlich eine ehre das
bundesministerium in diesem hause nicht
nur in der rolle als stellvertretender
vorsitz des rechtsausschusses sondern
eben auch haushalterisch begleiten zu
dürfen drei themen möchte ich heute
ansprechen
erst der rechtsstaat ist die schon
angesprochen einer der wesentlichen
grundpfeiler unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung und über den
etat dieses grundpfeiler sprechen wir
heute das ist wichtig zu betonen denn
das vertrauen in justiz und rechtsstaat
ist gerade in herausfordernden zeiten in
zeiten der krise besonders notwendig
demokratie und rechtsstaat sind nämlich
keine schönwetter ereignisse und
schönwetter institutionen sie beweisen
gerade in der krise ihren wert und
gerade in der krise sind wir gemeinsam
als demokratinnen und demokraten
gefordert diese werte des rechtsstaats
zu verteidigen
heute vor genau einem monat am 24
februar
2022 sind wir zeugen und zeugen geworden
des völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine ein besonders
perfider massiver eingriff in demokratie
freiheit und rechtsstaatlichkeit
man mag die frage aufwerfen was hat das
mit dem rechtsstaat hier zu tun ich sage
sehr sehr viel denn im rechtsstaat
schließe ich mich den bundesminister
gerne an gehört auch diese rechtliche
aufarbeitung eines völkerrechtlichen
angriffskrieges maßgeblich dazu und wir
können stolz darauf sein mit der
generalbundesanwaltschaft und diesem
land eine institution zu haben die
besonders aktiv und besonders kompetent
in der lage ist derartige sachverhalte
aufzuklären und aus zu ermitteln darauf
setzen wir auch alle gemeinsam für die
aufarbeitung dieses krieges in der
ukraine liebe freundinnen und freunde
und wir werden selbstverständlich in den
haushaltsberatungen auch sehr genau
darauf gucken ob wir das auch mit dem
was angesetzt ist ermöglichen denn um es
klar zu sagen
auch im krieg auch im konflikt sind es
wir als freiheitliche demokratie die den
rechtsstaatlichen kompass nicht
verlieren und auch das unterscheidet
eine demokratie von einer diktatur
zum zweiten punkt
digitalisierung von justiz und
rechtsstaat bietet war große chancen und
zwar insbesondere auch für den zugang
der bürgerinnen und bürger zum recht zum
rechtsschutz und dazu haben wir uns als
koalition besonders ambitionierte
vorhaben aus ausgedacht die verstetigung
des paktes für den rechtsstaat gehört
dazu ergänzt durch einen digital tat
packt aber eben auch vereinfachte
verfahren für klein forderungen bei
niemandem soll der zugang zum recht
daran scheitern dass die forderung zu
klein oder das geld zu wenig ist liebe
freunde
dennoch ist wichtig als sparsamer
haushälter auch an einer stelle zu
betonen pakt für den rechtsstaat
bedeutet wenn wir aus bundesmitteln dort
gemeinsam mit den ländern zu lösungen
kommen dass der gemeinsam mit den
ländern dazu kommen müssen welche die
richtigen wege und die richtigen
entscheidungen gibt es geht nicht darum
ein füllhorn auszuschütten sondern
gemeinsam als bund und länder dafür
sorgen dass die gezielt die
digitalisierung zu dem erfolg bringen in
der justiz den wir alle gemeinsam
möchten
eines möchte ich besonders besonders
hinweisen an der stelle 20 jahre anwalts
erfahrung zeigen mir dass es besonders
in diesen bereichen notwendig ist dass
wir alle beteiligten an den tisch
bekommen dazu gehören die anwälte dazu
da gehören aber auch berufe wie die
rechtspflegerin und rechtspfleger auch
das gerichtsvollzieher wesen dazu ich
halte es für notwendig dass wir bei
allen verhandlungen und detailplanung
mit allen gemeinsam dafür sorgen den
sprung in das digitalisierungs zeitalter
gemeinsam zudem zu führen was wir wollen
es sichert die funktionsfähigkeit des
rechtsstaates dass es unser aller
gemeinsame aufgabe und diese ampel wird
an dieser stelle liefern und den
modernsten digitalen und funktionstasten
rechtsstaat in europa zu gewährleisten
vielen dank
[Applaus]
sehen auch und weiterhin schauen wir mit
einem auge nach brüssel da treffen sich
übrigens auch die regierung staaten der
regierungschefs der g 7 staaten auch im
nato hauptquartier beraten sie auch zur
gleichen zeit sie die nato und da haben
sie dort auch eben
auto wegfahren gesehen
volker ullrich spricht jetzt im
deutschen bundestag sprecher für rechte
csu landesgruppe
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren der etat des
bundesjustizministeriums hat das
geringste volumen aller
einzelpläne und es würde nur gut zwei
tage reichen um die sozialetats
abzudecken er ist dennoch von
elementarer bedeutung
weil wir wissen dass rechtsstaatlichkeit
demokratie begründet
und weil dieser etat auch mit dem
deutschen patent und markenamt
grundlegend den schutz des geistigen
eigentums begründet und das deutsche
patent und markenamt und diese hinweis
sei mir gestattet
hat einnahmen von 450 millionen euro
rund und dem stehen gegenüber 255
millionen euro ausgaben
das zeigt wie gut dieses amt arbeitet
aber es deutet auch darauf hin dass
möglicherweise gerade des start-ups und
unternehmer gründer bei der frage der
gebühren für geistiges eigentum formaten
anmeldungen noch raum für senkungen
besteht um damit die
unternehmensgründung auch im bereich des
geistigen eigentums zu verbessern
wir müssen in diesem haushalt auch über
den generalbundesanwalt sprechen und
zwar ganz konkret wegen des krieges in
der ukraine hier finden
kriegsverbrechen statt diese müssen
dokumentiert werden aber entscheidend
ist auch dass wohl im hintergrund des
weltrechtsprinzip
es nirgendwo auf der welt eine zuflucht
für kriegsverbrecher geben darf und
rechtspolitisch muss ganz klar sein
kriegsverbrechen gehören aufgeklärt
angeklagt und abgeurteilt und dazu
braucht die justiz die kapazitäten und
wenn der generalbundesanwalt für
dokumentation und struktur
ermittlungsverfahren mehr stellen
braucht muss er sie jetzt bekommen
wir sprechen auch über die frage bis
funktionieren des rechtsstaats und
da möchte ich klar und deutlich zum
ausdruck bringen der rechtsstaat in
deutschland funktioniert er arbeitet
korrekt wer immer den eindruck erwecken
möchte der rechtsstaat würde nicht
ordnungsgemäß funktionieren stellt sich
auf die seite derjenigen die aus anderen
motiven den rechtsstaat in misskredit
bringen möchten das sind feinde der
freiheit wir stehen zum recht dass in
deutschland verwirklicht wird
aber natürlich muss dieser rechtsstaat
besser werden das bedeutet er muss
digitaler werden
ich finde es gut und richtig dass der
digital packt der justiz weiter
fortgeführt wird und dass die frage wie
können wir verfahren nicht nur im
strafrechts bereich sind auch im
zivilrecht bereich digitale gestalten
eine zentrale rolle erhält
wir müssen auch dafür sorge tragen dass
im strafverfahren
ein paradigmenwechsel dergestalt
eintreten kann das vielleicht auch die
hauptverhandlungen
wort für wort protokolliert werden ob er
deswegen eine audiovisuelle aufzeichnung
brauchen das wage ich infrage stellen
aber ich glaube dass durch
digitalisierung hier mehr raum entsteht
um strafverfahren auch aufzuzeichnen und
damit auch die frage von rechtsmitteln
praktikabler zu gestalten aber wenn über
den digitalen bereich sprechen dann
dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass in der
digitalen sphäre auch grausame
straftaten entstehen und dort auch ihren
raum haben ich denke einen drogenhandel
im parkett ich denke auch an die
furchtbaren verbrechen des
kindesmissbrauchs und der
kinderpornografie und in diesem
zusammenhang braucht der rechtsstaat
auch die entscheidenden
aufklärungs instrumentarien und ich weiß
dass man über einzelheiten der
vorratsdaten speicherung trefflich
verfassungsrechtlich streiten kann aber
die vorratsdatenspeicherung in abrede zu
stellen wäre vor dem hintergrund des
aufklärungs bedürfnis des staates mehr
als fahrlässig wir halten daran fest
möchte auch bei dem thema des
rechtspolitischen dialogs zwischen bund
und ländern noch kurs auf das thema
impfpflicht zu sprechen es gibt einen
gesetzentwurf
den der bundeskanzler der vizekanzler
auch der bundesgesundheitsminister in
ihrer funktion als abgezeichnet haben
es geht es nicht um die
gesundheitspolitische bewertungen dieses
gesetzentwurfes aber
was mir bei diesem entwurf fehlt und
diese frage muss diskutiert werden ist
nämlich der umstand was macht das denn
eigentlich mit unserer justiz auf der
ebene der amtsgerichte wenn wir eine
situation gegenüber stehen bei dem
möglicherweise hunderttausende von neuen
bußgeldverfahren haben im rahmen der
impfpflicht dass in diesem gesetzentwurf
zum thema justiz praktisch nichts steht
zeigt dass hier ein großer nachholbedarf
besteht meine damen und herren
ich kann nur darauf hinweist dass bei
der schwerpunktsetzung ist darum gehen
muss die aktuellen herausforderungen des
rechts abzubilden dass neben der frage
digitalisierung auch das soziale
mietrecht es geht darum dass im bereich
des mietrechts zu regeln was den
menschen auf den nägeln brennt die frage
der kündigungen beispielsweise oder der
weiter ansteigenden mietpreis ich glaube
dass eine fokussierung dass eine
fokussierung auf themen die er dem
koalitionsfrieden dienen die pubs oder
19a nicht im mittelpunkt der
rechtspolitischen agenda stehen sollte
es geht
abschließend darum dass wir das recht
verteidigen und deutlich machen dass
freie demokratie recht voraussetzt und
dass wir recht nicht diskreditieren
sondern es in den etappen abbilden aber
lassen sie uns gemeinsam über diese
notwendigen verbesserungen sprechen
herzlichen dank
so fordert es volker ullrich sprecher
für rechte
csu-landesgruppe hier in der debatte zum
etat des
bundesjustizministeriums buschmann
935 millionen euro sind in diesem jahr
für das ministerium vorgesehen sonja ich
weder spricht jetzt sprechen für rechte
spd fraktion
wer die frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen fraktionen der haushalt
des bundesministeriums der justiz ist im
vergleich zu anderen einzelplänen recht
klein in seiner leistung und reichweite
aber bei weitem nicht zu unterschätzen
gerade in der heutigen zeit einen monat
nach dem völkerrechtswidrigen überfall
und anderes tricks putins auf die
ukraine und einheit denn der wir
weltweit die zunahme von autoritären
regime haben ist es wichtig einen gut
funktionierenden rechtsstaat nach innen
und nach außen zu haben
aus diesem grund begrüßen wir
ausdrücklich die entscheidung des
internationalen
gerichtshofes den angriffskrieg als
völkerrechtswidrig darzustellen und food
ihnen auch zu fordern die
kriegshandlungen sofort einzustellen der
minister wies darauf hin nach innen es
ist sehr sehr wichtig dass der
generalbundesanwalt
entsprechende ermittlungen die schon
angesprochen wurden aufgenommen hat in
der ampelkoalition arbeiten wir
gemeinsam an der fortentwicklung der
modernisierung und der stärkung unseres
rechtsstaats denn es gilt die stärkung
des recht und nicht das recht des
stärkeren
hierfür sind gerade die
haushaltsentscheidungen und
verhandlungen natürlich entscheiden denn
insbesondere auch die ausstattung der
obersten bundesgerichte und des
generalbundesanwalts haben hier einen
unermesslichen stellenwert hinter dem
vermeintlichen standardtitel
finanzierung der bundesgerichte verbirgt
sich folglich das rückgrat unseres
rechtsstaats
besonders herauszustellen ist dabei dass
gerade während der korona pandemie an
unseren gerichten und ist nicht nur auf
bundesebene die wir hier heute
besprechen fortwährend ein erhöhtes maß
an arbeit unter besonders schwierigen
bedingungen geleistet wurde denn die
arbeit konnte nicht verkürzt werden sie
musste fortwährend weiter geführt werden
hierfür gebührt allen kolleginnen und
kollegen in der justiz unser aufrechter
dank
denn mit jedem blick in jede akte machen
sie unseren rechtsstaat lebendig hier
ist jeder einzelne cent sehr sehr gut
investiertes geld
darüber hinaus bietet der haushaltsplan
auch weitere unterstützung und zuschüsse
für wichtige organisationen die unser
demokratisches zusammenleben
und unsere sicherheit fördern wie auch
hand in hand mit den vorhaben der
koalitionsparteien gehen notwendige
rechtliche veränderungen in unserem land
anzustreben dafür möchte ich hier drei
beispiele
herausgreifen erster hass und hetze im
internet sind täglich präsent
betroffenen wiederum muss aber
orientierung gegeben werden und sie mit
mussin hilfe zuteil werden wie sie
juristische möglichkeiten nutzen können
die organisation hate setzt genau hier
an bietet kostenlose beratung für
betroffene und die möglichkeit
prozesskosten finanzierung zu beantragen
diese förderung ist unglaublich wichtig
denn fast ist keine meinung
zweitens die stärkung unserer
demokratischen zivilgesellschaft und der
kampf gegen rechtsextremismus rassismus
und antisemitismus muss weiter
vorangetrieben werden gerade in den
heutigen zeiten deshalb ist die weitere
förderung der amadeu antonio stiftung
sowie des anne frank zentrums elementar
den rechtsextremismus ist die größte
gefahr für demokratie und rechtsstaat
wenn dieser beratung zu leben
und drittens ein weiteres sehr wichtiges
thema aus einem anderen bereich in die
förderung des vereins gewaltfreiheit in
die zukunft ev bringt den kampf gegen
häusliche gewalt in form einer non
profit ab ins digitale zeitalter
durch diese f wird betroffenen hilfe
angeboten es wird ihnen hinweisen zu
einrichtungen und frauenhäusern
bereitgestellt und somit einen weg aus
der gewalt aufgezeigt denn hier müssen
wir nicht nur rechtlich bessere weichen
stellen sondern auch darüber hinaus
handeln deshalb begrüße ich diese
förderung sehr
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
zwar ist der umfang des plans durch den
wegfall des verbraucherschutzes was
schon angesprochen wurde etwas kleiner
geworden aber wir wissen auch den
verbraucherschutz bei unseren
kolleginnen und kollegen
umweltministerium sehr gut aufgehoben
bei den themen die noch bei uns liegen
die umsetzung der verbandsklage
richtlinie werden wir uns mit herzblut
einbringen
zusammenfassend ist aber zum haushalt
hier im einzelplan 07 zu sagen er ist
vielfältiger als er auf den ersten blick
erscheint er enthält hoch aktuelle titel
ist gerade in unserer jetzigen zeit
wichtig denn wir müssen den rechtsstaat
stärken und schützen und wir brauchen
diese projekte auch um die
verantwortungsvolle politik für die wir
als ampel stehen umzusetzen
ob wir verbesserungen
erweiterungspotenzial sehen werden wir
uns eigene einbringen in den
verhandlungen ebenso werden wir weiter
an der fortsetzung der pakt des paktes
für den rechtsstaat des digital paktes
arbeiten um der justiz die unterstützung
in personal und ausstattung zukommen zu
lassen die sie braucht ich freue mich
auf die anstehenden beratungen und
verbleibe mit herzlichen dank und freue
mich auf die weitere debatte
so
liebte war das in ihrer rede hat sie
unter anderem auch auf hass kriminalität
im internet hingewiesen
dass parlamentarischen kontrollgremiums
die zeit für die wahl ist vorbei es ist
auch sichergestellt dass die mitglieder
des parallel tagen in ältestenrates ihre
stimme abgeben konnten gleichwohl trage
ich ist noch ein mitglied des hauses
anwesend dass seine stimme nicht
abgegeben hat ich bitte das jetzt zügig
zu vollziehen ich werde in jedem fall
nach dem nächsten redebeitrag dann die
wahl schließen so bundestags
vizepräsidentin petra pau erinnert hier
nochmal an die wahl für das
parlamentarische kontrollgremium das ist
hier ein
gremium das die kontrolle der
nachrichtendienste
dafür zuständig ist diese überwacht zum
beispiel den bundesnachrichtendienst
für die fw fraktion spricht jetzt fabian
jacobi
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
sie alle kennen den berühmten dialog aus
dem film der pate
amerigo oder das tochter ist von zwei
jungen männern misshandelt worden das
gericht hat die täter laufen lassen und
nun erscheint sprossen dabei mafia paten
don corleone um dort auf anderem wege
genugtuung für geschehenes unrecht zu
erwirken
eine eindringliche künstlerische
darstellung der erkenntnis dass der
rechtsstaat nicht allein aus
gerichtsgebäuden und gesetzbüchern
besteht sondern dass er steht und fällt
mit dem vertrauen das die bürger in ihn
setzen
eng damit verknüpft ist die alte frage
wer eigentlich die wächter privat oder
im vorliegenden kontext die frage wer
die wächter beziehungsweise richter
zuallererst einsetzt damit bin ich bei
dem was das justiz ressort nachdem
regierungsvertrag in dieser wahlperiode
tun soll zitat wir reformieren die wahl
für richter an den obersten
bundesgerichten nicht deutlich wird ob
das bundesverfassungsgericht mit
angesprochen ist dabei wäre gerade dies
dringlich denn wegen seiner besonders
herausragenden rolle im staate wird sich
hier der vertrauensverlust besonders
nachteilig aus dass es diesen gibt wird
hoffentlich niemand bestreiten wollen
ich zitiere die überschrift eines
artikels der im september in der
zeitschrift cicero erschienen ist corona
klima rundfunkbeitrag karlsruhe
entwickelt sich immer mehr zum
erfüllungsgehilfen der politik für
unsere demokratie ist das
brandgefährlich wohin steuert das
bundesverfassungsgericht zitat ende ein
beispiel von vielen nach dem grundgesetz
werden die richter von bundestag und
bundesrat gewählt in der praxis hat eine
gruppe von vier parteien cdu csu spd fdp
und grüne das gericht unter sich
aufgeteilt und besetzt reibung die
richter stühle das ist kein besonderes
geheimnis das kann man wenn man sich
dafür interessiert immer wieder lesen
wir haben bereits einer zurückliegenden
periode den vorschlag gemacht die
richterwahl von den politischen parteien
weg zu verlagern und hin zu einem
wahlgremium das aus der justiz selbst
besetzt wird das ist hier einhellig
abgelehnt worden wenn aber weiterhin die
besetzung des verfassungsgerichts durch
parteipolitiker erfolgen soll dann muss
man über andere reformansätze reden
derzeit geschieht die wahl von
verfassungsrichtern ohne aussprache als
begründung wird angeführt eine
öffentliche erörterung führe zu einer
politisierung des gerichts die aber
verhindert werden müsse dass nun ist
bestenfalls eine lebenslüge
schlimmstenfalls heuchelei die funktion
des verfassungsgerichts ist per se eine
hochpolitische und es wird von
parteipolitikern besetzt anderswo etwa
in amerika geht man weitaus offener und
dadurch auch ehrlicher und dort werden
die kandidaten vor ihrer berufung einem
von der demokratischen öffentlichkeit
mit zu verfolgenden anhörungs prozess
unterzogen das notwendige vertrauen in
die integrität des gerichts dürfte ein
solches verfahren weitaus eher fördern
als die vorgehensweise wie hierzulande
praktiziert wird letzter satz
das verfahren der richterwahl ist
zentral für den rechtsstaat wir geben
die hoffnung nicht auf dass sinnvolle
reform auch hier im hause möglich sein
werden vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich komme noch mal zurück zur folge mit
glieder des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums die zeit für die wahl
ist vorbei
ist noch ein mitglied des hauses
anwesend welches seine stimme nicht ab
oder besser stimme nicht abgegeben hat
das ist nicht der fall ich schließe die
wahl und bitte die schriftführerin und
schriftführer mit der auszählung zu
beginnen das ergebnis der wahl wird
ihnen später bekannt gegeben
damit haben wir nun auch die notwendige
aufmerksamkeit hergestellt zur ersten
rede im deutschen bundestag die der
kollege lukas becker für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen erste corona
pandemie und dann vor einem monat auch
noch der schreckliche angriffskrieg auf
dem kreml
selbstverständlichkeiten sind ebensolche
nicht mehr und es braucht eine politik
die dem gerecht wird eine politik die
anpassungsfähig ist lieber auch
selbstkritisch ist und die vor allen
dingen in diesen schwierigen zeiten sehr
kritisch hinschaut und das geld in das
richtige investiert
gerade im justizbereich kosten die
meisten verbesserungen aber gar kein
geld und das ist das positive an dieser
stelle denn wir brauchen gerade jetzt
eine starke demokratie und dafür eine
leistungsfähige justiz und ein recht auf
höhe der zeit leider finden wir genau
das nicht vor denn im rechtsbereich
liegen 16 jahren reformstau vor uns
liegen 16 jahre hinter uns in denen
gesellschaftlicher wandel gerade nicht
in gesetze geflossen ist und da draußen
leben menschen deren lebensrealität sich
eben nicht in unseren gesetzen
widerspiegelt und genau das stört das
vertrauen ins recht
[Applaus]
in der justiz haben die mitarbeitenden
in und vor der korona pandemie großes
geleistet aber eine leistungsfähige
justiz besteht eben nicht nur aus
aufopfernden mitarbeitenden sondern sie
braucht eine vernünftige ausstattung ein
vernünftiges system
wir sind in der pandemie im bereich der
digitalisierung sehr viel weiter
gekommen als wir uns das vorher gedacht
haben aber trotzdem ist in den
amtsgerichten in der fläche die abkehr
vom faxgerät und von der papierakte
immer noch die große herausforderung da
müssen wir ran
der rückstau von gestern behindert die
entscheidung von morgen und deswegen bin
ich so froh herr bundesminister
buschmann dass wir mit ihnen jemanden
haben der die digitalisierung ernst
meint wie man im referentenentwurf von
gestern sehen kann und deswegen den wir
gemeinsam als ampel dieses thema an wir
geben jetzt schon mehr geld für
digitalisierung der justiz aus und wir
arbeiten am digital pakt für die justiz
um hier voranzugehen
dem aber nicht genug wir wollen für eine
effektive rechtsmittel kontrolle im
strafprozess verhandlungen digital
protokollieren wir wollen den
bürgerinnen und bürgern die möglichkeit
geben ihre ansprüche schnell und
unkompliziert durchzusetzen und mit der
gleichen maßnahme amtsgerichte entlasten
und deswegen wollen wir ermöglichen dass
man klein forderungen digitalen prozess
durchsetzen kann und wenn die kraft mal
nicht reicht oder der gegner finanziell
zu übermächtig ist wollen wir es
bürgerinnen und bürgern ermöglichen sich
zusammenzuschließen und deswegen stärken
wir den kollektiven rechtsschutz noch
weiter
[Applaus]
die digitalisierung ist eine große
chance für eine leistungsfähige justiz
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und jetzt
endlich endlich können wir
gesellschaftliche realität in gesetze
gießen jetzt endlich können wir dafür
sorgen dass nach 16 jahren stillstand
wie ein recht auf höhe der zeit haben
und das ist für uns als fortschritts
koalition die ganz große aufgabe
in keinem bereich wird das so deutlich
wie im familienrecht und deswegen
ermöglichen wir es lesbischen ehepaar
dass wenn ein kind geboren wird sofort
beide mutter sind und deswegen
ermöglichen wir eine elternschaft
anerkennung unabhängig von geschlecht
und ehe und deswegen ermöglichen wir
menschen für die die er nicht das
konstrukt der wahl ist rechtlich
verbindlich verantwortung füreinander zu
übernehmen weil das ist längst
überfällig
dem nicht genug
wir schaffen ein selbstbestimmung gesetz
und ja herr doktor krings wir schaffen
29 10 ich freue mich auf ihre fachlichen
ausführungen aber das ist längst
überfällig denn wir wollen informationen
ermöglichen und nichts anderes
und weil uns die nachrichten erreichen
ja natürlich wir legalisieren auf
cannabis
denn wenn sich menschen in recht und
gesetz und sich lebensrealitäten in
recht und gesetz wiederfinden dann
stärkt das vertrauen aber ein recht auf
höhe der zeit ist hier nicht nur verließ
ich zu verstehen sondern noch dringender
denn je auch mit blick auf die realität
da draußen die rede ist von energie
souveränität wir müssen planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen und
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
energiewende aufgrund von guten gesetzen
von klaren auslegungs regelungen und von
vernünftigen gesetzen bis in die fläche
nicht an den gerichten scheitert
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen recht ist
kein selbstzweck es steht im dienste der
bürgerinnen und bürger und genau diesen
schulden wir eine leistungsfähige justiz
und ein recht auf höhe der zeit gehen
wir es gemeinsam an vielen dank
sie forderten diskutieren über den
einzelplan 07 uhr das
bundesjustizministerium und es ist nun
mal in der natur dieses ministeriums das
in erster linie ein gesetzgebungs
ministerium ist und auch die anderen
ministerien berät bei der vorbereitung
der rechts gesetzesvorhaben das hier
auch eben ein eine große palette an
themen angesprochen wird susanne hier
spricht jetzt hier zum ersten mal im
deutschen bundestag sie ist aus der
unions fraktion und mitglied im
rechtsausschuss
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir diskutieren heute den
betragsmäßig kleinsten haushalt aller
ministerien
wenn wir es vergleichen manch einer
behauptet sogar es wäre die
langweiligste debatte dieser woche die
wir führen dieser meinung bin ich nicht
einmal ein paar projekte der ampel
werfen die diese legislatur vorgesehen
sind da ist zum einen die verbesserung
der qualität der gesetzgebung bei neuen
vorhaben soll frühzeitig und ressort
übergreifend diskutiert werden auch in
neuen formaten die praxis soll mit
einbezogen werden vor allem die
betroffenen und auch die erfahrungen und
bedürfnisse der länder und kommunen
sollen mit einbezogen werden das begrüße
ich auf 400 prozent aber wie sieht denn
die umsetzung in der praxis aus nehmen
wir zum beispiel die einführung der
sektoralen impfpflicht zum ende des
letzten jahres
ich kann mir schwer vorstellen dass hier
eine frühzeitige einbeziehung der
betroffenen erfolgt ist der
verantwortlichen in den einrichtungen
der pflegerinnen und pfleger der
kommunen und länder anders kann ich es
mir nicht erklären dass die diskussion
um eine durchsetzbarkeit dieser
impfpflicht erst wochen nach abschluss
des gesetzgebungsverfahrens fahrt
aufgenommen hat hier haben sie noch viel
luft nach oben um ihre eigenen ansprüche
zu erfüllen
weiter
wollen sie den gesetzen eine synopse mit
beifügen das heißt der aktuelle
rechtslage
auch die neue geänderte rechtslage
gegenüberstellen für die anwender in der
praxis wie zum beispiel anwälte
steuerberater oder auch behörden wäre
das eine wirkliche erleichterung
bisher kann ich davon aber nichts
feststellen
inhaltlich
kündigte das ministerium an die unter
anderem die größte reform des
familienrechts
einzuführen das wohl des kindes soll
hierbei zentral sein heißt es im
koalitionsvertrag
es geht um die ausweitung des kleinen
sorgerechts es geht um änderungen im
unterhalts- und um und es geht auch um
die verantwortungsgemeinschaft
das sind themen die millionen von
menschen bei uns im land betreffen trägt
man aber nach einem zeitlichen
umsetzungs zeitpunkt so kann das
ministerium keine nennen
stattdessen kümmert man sich mit
hochdruck um die abschaffung des
paragraphen 219 aus strafgesetzbuch
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ganz
ehrlich ist dass unser größtes und
verträglich das problem das wir momentan
zu lösen haben
[Applaus]
die abschätzung des werbeverbots für den
schwangerschaftsabbruch und herr
minister ich kann gut verstehen dass so
schnelle erfolge wollen und in der
legislatur sehr früh ihr lieblingsthema
durchsetzen das kann man so machen aber
ich meine sie setzen die prioritäten
völlig falsch
ich hoffe dass das ministerium
bei allen vorhaben die kommen über den
tellerrand hinaus sieht und wirklich die
bedürfnisse der praxis mit in die
gesetzgebungs initiativen mit einbezieht
die betroffenen würden es ihnen danken
seien sie sich versichert wir werden
alle projekte ganz genau beobachten und
werden uns weiterhin tatkräftig mit
einbringen haben sie herzlichen dank
susanne scheel war das erste rede und
die hat sie nach freigehalten das fällt
schon auf werden hier jemand ohne zettel
nach vorne geht und sich auch noch
innerhalb der redezeit
zum schluss kommt johannes technisch
spricht jetzt für den spd fraktion
minister buschmann liebe zu können und
zu unserer haushaltsberatungen werden
natürlich und auch zurecht überlagert
vom brutalen angriffskrieg von putin auf
die ukraine wir sind alle immer noch
entsetzt aber wir stehen ganz fest an
der seite der ukraine und eines ist
dabei klar das will ich gerade in einer
rechts politischen debatte ausdrücklich
auch so sagen diesen brutalen überfall
den dulden wir nicht es muss die stärke
des rechts gelten und nicht das recht
des stärkeren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und gerade in der rechtspolitik und auch
mit diesem haushalt da werden wir uns
dafür einsetzen dass konflikte und
streitigkeiten gerade auf
internationaler ebene
friedlich gelöst werden und zwar in
rechtsstaatlichen verfahren wir machen
mit diesem haushalt viel zum beispiel
unterstützen wir wichtige internationale
einrichtungen wie die wto den
internationalen seegerichtshof oder auch
ganz besonders wichtig für uns die
rechtsstaatliche aufbauarbeit der
gesellschaft für internationale
rechtliche zusammenarbeit also wir
leisten mit diesem haushalt wirklich
einen beitrag dafür dass solche
konflikte auf international friedlich
gelöst werden kolleginnen und kollegen
unternehmen uns rechtspolitisch auch in
dieser wahlperiode sehr viel vor wir
haben uns einiges vorgenommen
dazu gehört es dass wir im strafrecht
genau prüfen welche vorschrift brauchen
wir überhaupt noch denn wir wollen eine
effektive kriminalpolitik und dann
gehört es eben dazu dass wir endlich den
paragrafen 219 a für den es kein
praktisches bedürfnis mehr geht
streichen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das will ich hier deutlich sagen wenn
frauen in schwieriger lage sind dann
waren sie schnell und einfach zugang zu
informationen und es kann einfach nicht
sein dass ärzte schwangerschaftsabbrüche
vornehmen dürfen darüber wird nicht
sachlich informieren dürfen und deswegen
werden wir diesen widerspruch auflösen
im übrigen wird die werbung für
schwangerschafts abbrüche auch nicht
zulässig seien es gibt weiterhin das
ärztliche standesrecht also schneiden
wir diesen alten zopf endlich ab es ist
gut dass wir als eines der ersten
projekte in der ampelkoalition diese
nicht mehr notwendige vorschrift des 219
endlich streichen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
starten sie eine frage oder bemerkung
aus der cdu/csu logo
ich wusste doch wer es macht
ihr kollege wenn man die diskussion
schon öfter geführt und wissen auch wo
wir stehen und die argumente sind
ausgetauscht
ich möchte aber dann doch hier nochmal
fragen wir sind ja in der rechts debatte
und zu dem thema 219 hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ja auch
ausführliche urteile gemacht und da wäre
jetzt meiner frage das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt das
ungeborene kind entwickelte sich von
anfang an als mensch und nicht zum
menschen es hat von anfang an
menschenwürde und lebensrecht und das
kommt in der diskussion die wir hier
führen also doch sehr kurz und ich würde
jetzt mal ihre haltung so und wir
verlassen die debatte jetzt